لا للتعويني او التطبيع جمل يتفق عليها
اغلب سكان الرقه وموجها وعشائرها الى جانب
الادارتين العسكريه والمدنيه في رفض واضح
للتقارب بين النظام السوري وتركيا
تركيا هي كانت السبب الوحيد في تهجير
السوريين وقتل السوريين وذبح السوريين
ودمار المحافظه باكملها
بشكل عام على الاتراك الاتراك بالنهايه هم
احتلال وقاموا بتدمير سوريا
ويرى وجهاء وعشائر ان تركيا تستخدم ورقه
التطبيع مع الاسد لاهداف انتخابيه خالصه
على حساب معاناه السوريين
وجراحهم التي لم تندمل بعد
16 مليون من الشعب السوري خارج
البيوت
خاصه بالانتخابات
وتخشى المدينه من ان تقود اي اتفاقيات
مستقبليه الى عوده النظام للانتقام من
السكان تحت دراعه كثيره او جلب ايران
واطلاق يدها على غرار ما يحدث في دير
الزور القريبه
هنا سواء من قبل تركيا واي
دوله
من مدينه الرقه شمال شرق سوريا جمعه كاش
العربيه